[Music]
venom was quite a surprise hit at the
box offices with a box office takings of
850 million US dollars only the new step
the film comes with a low rating pg-13
was a little bit disappointing to many
fans because even the made actor Tom
Hardy had wished for a much tougher
approach however this might not be the
case with a sequel because venom -
producer Matt Tomac puts this option in
the spotlight in an interview with
cinema blames a decisive factor for this
is the gigantic success of Joker which
could open the door for more brutal
superhero movies himself finds it
absolutely great that r-rated films are
now being accepted by a mass audience
which in turn means that there are more
opportunities to tell such stories a
confirmation that venom 2 actually
receives a higher age rating than its
predecessor however he didn't want to be
elicited nevertheless fans will be
pleased that the option at least exists
and is not unlikely but would that also
make sense in terms of contents in any
case with the introduction of the new
villain carnage who's played by Woody
Harrelson a more brutal approach might
make sense the name alone sounds
promising the shooting of venom 2 with
director Andy Serkis is already underway
which is why a decision regarding
brutality if it hasn't already been made
behind the scenes will be made anytime
soon venom 2 will be released in u.s.
American cinemas on October 2nd 2020 the
nominations for the Golden Globe Awards
77 have been announced a few days ago it
is no secret that the winners of the
Golden Globe also have a significantly
higher chance of winning an Oscar at
next year's Academy Awards which is why
the film world will be looking curiously
at the nominees almost everyone knows
and many loved Game of Thrones but does
the fantasy epic have a chance of
winning a prize after winning 12 Emmys
in September looks rather bad since the
only nomination goes to Jon Snow actor
Kit Harington as best serious actor has
to assert himself against Rama Malik
from mr. robots and other actors one of
the most important categories is best
film drama in which 1917 the two posts
Joker marriage story and the Irishman
Pete on the comedy films musical side
Joe Joe rabbit knives out who once upon
a time in Hollywood and rocket men among
others will compete in the supporting
actors category the men Tom Hanks and me
Hopkins Al Pacino Joe Pesci and Brad
Pitt compete for the prize while the
women Kathy Bates and a Benning Laura
Dern Jennifer Lopez and Margot Robbie
want the prize the last important
category is the best directing where
John hosts Sam Mendes Todd Phillips
Martin Scorsese and Quentin Tarantino
compete for the award Netflix is also
represented at the Golden Globes in a
rather disproportionate way because the
bottom line is that the streaming giant
has 34 nominations among the nominees
are Noah Baum bucks drama marriage story
with six nominations and Martin
Scorsese's the Irishman with five the
77s Golden Globe Awards will be
presented on January 5th 2020 in Beverly
Hills and hosted by a comedian Ricky
Gervais the MCU would probably look
different today if spider-man actor Tom
Holland hadn't drunk Lee convinced
Disney boss Bob Iger in October to
reconsider the deal between Sony and
Moffat at first it doesn't sound that
credible but Holland confirms this in
the late-night talk show with Jimmy
Kimmel they told that he would say it
was all his achievements yet with wink
he's convinced that he saved spider-man
but first back to the beginning the
unbelievable story begins in August of
this year when the 23 year old Holland's
advertised the Pixar film on watch at
the Disney fair d23 not exactly his best
day he says because around this time it
became known that the negotiations
between Disney and Sony regarding the
future of spider-man in the MCU have
failed at the fair he spoke out in favor
of the support of the fans who are
supporting spider-man and then even got
the email address from eige and
contacted him afterwards however the
topic was not about spider-man but about
the opportunity to thank him for the
last five years Bob Iger also seemed to
have responded quickly and called
Holland shortly afterwards as Holland
tells it at an inconvenient time for him
since Holland had already had three
beers and was not quite as sober anymore
in the following telephone conversation
even cried and convinced Agra so far
that he was said to have said that there
was a world in the negotiations with
Sony where you could do that the rest is
history because shortly afterwards the
turnaround happened and the deal was
extended to what extent Tom Hollands
actually contributed to this is of
course questionable but it could be that
he was the tip of the iceberg for
spider-man's future in the MCU it has
been known for some time that the third
part of the conjuring series won't be a
pure haunted house horror movie instead
the two ghost Honda's ed and Lorraine
Warren will be confronted with a whole
new kind of evil as the title of the
film which was revealed this week
suggests because it bears the name the
conjuring the devil made me do it
instead of a ghost house this time the
warrants will take care of a little boy
soul the story which will push the
self-proclaimed demonologist to their
limits is again based on true events and
deals with the first case in the history
of American justice in which a murder
suspect wants to claim demon possession
as a defense ground concluding words are
given by a leading actor Patrick Wilson
who told in an interview with The
Hollywood Reporter that the movie still
has the same framework it's still aired
in Lorraine again they will push their
characters to places they haven't gone
yet but the movie will be a really nice
addition because it's definitely a
completely different monster the
conjuring the devil made me do it will
be released on September 11th 2020 in
u.s. cinemas at the moment director
George Miller is still working on his
new movie 3,000 years of longing but the
next project after that is already fixed
namely Mad Max in the past there were
some financial problems with this
project so the fifth offshoot of the
series was often postponed
however this now seems to belong to the
Past because as the director announced
there was finally an agreement Miller
explains that he's already in the middle
of preparation that the story of Mad Max
isn't finished yet
and that another Mad Max part will
surely follow the directors already
stages the letter several times in the
past
allegedly even the script for the sequel
is already finished however we have to
wait quite some time until the shooting
starts because first of all the shooting
for our three
colleges of longing is scheduled to
start in March next year
[Music]